hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three simulator games now
there's a lot of simulator games out
there on the internet there's Euro Truck
Simulator there's going to the bathroom
simulator there's a simulator for pretty
much anything that you would want to do
so I've collected three of them I have
no idea if they're good I have no idea
if they're bad some are new some are
very old the first one is called grass
simulator and I don't know what grass
simulator is okay I hit mode select I
didn't hit start game I don't know what
what are we doing okay anyway we're
gonna just play classic cuz I don't know
if I can hand
okay ah yes okay
what is that does that give me more or
less time in this hellhole oh I should
ah this is what I wanted even more time
to experience the joy of grass simulator
[Music]
okay alright how long does this last
am i sprinting now I honestly can't why
is there a bench in the middle of this
alka what was that oh I guess I'm fine
now alright well that's just great
I don't even know who does that speed
things up it does nothing well fool on
me for assuming that this might have
done something okay alright then
oh I should have known I would have a
gun Oh
all right are you okay am I supposed to
try to shoot you when you pop your head
up for a fraction of a second oh close
one
oh come on all right well this is regard
damn dick ulis but I am impressed by the
bullet casings coming out of this gun
with unlimited ammo okay well I think
I've made my point of all the things
that I expected to happen
that was not one of them I don't even
want to know what all the other modes of
this game are do i oh oh
responsive very cool of course
one-handed tommy gun of course that that
sounds correct I always like to hold my
guns at dick Heights but then everyone
knows I'm in Oh
all of their heads I disagree zoom in
with my mace haha I'm good on this one
get ready for your ass to get whooped
uh-huh
just check in your prostate how does
that feel huh all right your reflexes
are very bad okay I'm just gonna whoop
on your ass for a little bit here all
right
is this supposed to be doing some okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
this wasn't a free-to-play game no no no
no no I paid
real money for the privilege of grass
simulator and I still don't understand
what it has to do with simulating grass
like the water you doing tree what are
you doing that's not right what are you
reaching for tree we'll go to the
basement all right got a dubstep mode
[Music]
oh oh oh whoa what what what what what
what okay all right well I'm [ __ ] out
of here I'm out I'm Audi okay all right
snow fall ah Skyrim well this looks
actually good well that still works but
this looks really nice and detailed and
well there's okay nevermind then I
stripping a bit it's very slippery out
here on the ice yeah I wish I could stop
falling for one second on this staircase
but alright oh hi hello how oak excuse
me again very slippery all right okay it
slipped okay alright just gonna keep
well alright I guess that's if I jump I
can't slip right
oh no edge of the world what was the
point of this what was the point of it
you're gonna tell me frosty what was the
point of all this
oh you holly-jolly bear okay I died over
go this way then oh no you know what I
regret going this
[Music]
we got everything regret everything I
regret everything everything is what I
regret why are you spinning stop
spinning
I have no weapons anymore I don't
understand it I guess I'm just gonna you
know accept that this is just life and
I'm just gonna perpetually trip on my
ass and fall flat on my face where the
hell does this lead does this lead
anywhere
it's just leading to anything am I going
somewhere can you help me please help
please I'm begging you to help me oh boy
it's got to lead somewhere right it's
not just gonna run into another
invisible wall I mean oh never mind all
right moving on next one Hellfire what
is oh oh I am fast all right well that
funny guy range I don't know what the
range okay oh ah yes of course
oh it's ah it's wonderful I can practice
my aim for my fortnight games ah good to
know I'm still bad Wow oh there's
another room oh boy awesome okay great
all right I'm leaving now okay bad disco
Oh we'll come at me bro okay oh my god I
don't get it I don't get it I don't get
it I don't get it nice guy I guess is
that stars that spit on my monitor
that's being illuminated okay all right
there's only one more thing and it's
online and uh yeah let's do this yeah
okay let's do it in the disco yeah okay
let's do this come on what is this what
what is this someone please play grass
simulator with me it's all my grandma
got for me for my birthday
oh I can't believe this isn't at the top
of everyone's list oh I got a good where
what knife yeah come here
wait there's so many weapons wait why
are there so many more weapons here than
there were before what well there's an
RPG you know I don't think anyone's
gonna join my game I can't leave I can't
I cannot leave there we go okay all
right I'm gonna leave now well that was
the first one all right so if you
thought that was great if you thought
that was something special then boy do I
have a game for you yes it's true you
can finally build a computer on a
computer yes I know
technology is accelerated to a point
beyond which we currently understand and
lo and behold not only are you able to
build a computer but you're able to
build a living off of building and
repairing computers for other people in
a game when I tell you about this game
know that I'm not exaggerating in any
capacity yes you really can build a
computer in a video game it yes you
really can make a living so here we go
on a brand new adventure probably my new
career for realsies to begin go to your
PC by the door and open the email
program on your desktop you've got mail
oh wow I'm so happy so happy Wow whoa
[Laughter]
blowing Wow jeolban at all the male comm
virus scan PC can boot to OS remove
viruses not plugged in well let's plug
this bad boy in I'm gonna work on this
PC you need to run a virus scan press 3
or the cable button and plug the monitor
keyboard power and Mouse in the back of
the want this one ok I got it you know
it I've got it
there we go Oh like a dream like a dream
oh yeah oh this is the good stuff
Oh run an HDMI hoove what are we plebs
here where's my DisplayPort oh alright
you get over there wow that cable should
not be going through the monitor should
it okay let's turn her on let's log on
the computer my computer click
add/remove programs install the virus
scanner and don't forget to restart the
PC after it has been installed what is
my life oh I need to plug the USB in do
I have a program mmm let me look let me
look on my shelf oh I wonder what
components that I should use
whew I need to find I need to get some
sort of like a USB stick that has like
the program on it right I don't know
where that would be okay do I have it
here email thanks for taking over the PC
shop for me sorry it's not in the better
state a few things the company isn't
doing very well so there's no money in
the bank Thanks thank you great the rent
and energy bills come out monthly so
make sure you have enough money for them
oh great wonderful I'm so glad I took
this over I had a job on the go which
should help with the rent see the email
below remember to use your thermal paste
when putting on a CPU I almost always
forget in the PCs overheat oh my god do
I have an inventory oh there this that
how do I do that
okay oh oh oh oh here we go
but this yes I did it did I do it I did
it okay what happens if I just yank
these goddamn [ __ ] wires all over the
plate oh [ __ ] ah oh all better now okay
I got it I did I inserted it it's in
there oh it's not in there anymore oh
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ] god damn it okay all right Oh oh
that was way too sexual for my own good
there
so let's scan this virus and let's let's
build this career up let's pay our rent
come on oh we start now yes go it's so
realistic all right let's do this
wow that is not realistic at all oh boy
500 - 500 just as easy as that
oh just as easy okay all done
alright place it in my corridor let's
shut you down
are we loaded
[Laughter]
hey there I just wanted to say thank you
for Oh it's booting faster than it has
in years I didn't realize your uncle had
gone away looks like okay can you stop
please everybody stop I just started I
don't know what I'm doing please leave
me alone uh looks like the business is
in good hands
oh that music is too loud music player
can you blissful silence this is how I
like my game in complete and utter
silence in fact I'd rather have there be
some creepy ambiance over this because
there's something inherently creepy
about pretty much everything that I'm
doing here so let's have a scream
oh very nice okay now that's better all
right I need some more space to back up
my files could you install a 500
gigabyte hard drive along my existing
Drive I'll bring it round first thing
first thing what first thing tomorrow
first thing as soon as I responds his
email broken graphical card okay remove
viruses clean out dust yeah I'm gonna go
with this one we're gonna dentist oh
it's gonna be disgusting I'm gonna tip
this over there's gonna be teeth falling
out of it okay customers PCs will take a
day to arrive so end the current day by
going to the workshop door okay
do it all let's do it all but I'm doing
the dusting first let's do it all all
right they're in transit okay all right
wow what a satisfactory day I'm so happy
go to work Oh Oh
scan hello I'm gonna scan it hello here
you go there you go there I'm so happy
I'm so happy
wait hang on wait a minute I'm trying
I'm really trying you're oh I did it oh
oh it's doing it there's just no sound
to it ah why isn't there a sound added a
sound here it is there we go all right
she's a beaut she's a goddamn beaut all
right let's let's put her back together
put that back on screw er in nice and
tight
and yes I feel good about my life all
right let's install the old virus
and doing okay all right look you know
these people shouldn't trust me with
their computers especially full
unrestricted access to their computers
like this cuz that's a problem that is a
goddamn problem okay easy peasy
let's you know let's go the extra mile
let's delete this all right
just because I'm such a good guy I'm
such a good guy looking at every little
nuance of these people's computers right
no God I'm so nice this is really my
life I am legitimately just literally
put I don't know like reality hit me for
a second there like all the sudden it
was like I am playing a game where I am
literally fixing a computer something I
do enjoy doing in my life but not
something I occupy my spare time with I
I really really AM questioning my own
sanity at this point why why am I still
playing why am I still playing why would
I still play be playing this game why
would I say can I can I please blow this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right okay all right let's
remove oh wait I can't all gotta undo
the cable I can't away undo the cable no
that's not what I wanted to do how do i
how do I undo the cable we're gonna pick
up old [ __ ] all right I picked it all
off me happy alright let's remove it
wait
Oh No Oh Oh No why do I have to buy it
why do i why do I have to buy it that
means it's not gonna come today same-day
delivery perfect my purchases Wow
thank you thank you I'm gonna lose money
on this job thank you
all right well let's work on this PC ah
man broken let's sell that [ __ ] alright
put you in there
whomp easy peasy lemon squeezy
alright they seem to be overlooking the
entire everything goes wrong hearts DOA
unless that is a thing that can happen
in this game because parts arriving dead
dead on arrival DOA
that is a very extremely thing that
happens which is also words English that
I did where's the power button on this
[ __ ] there it is
alright did that does it boot it boots
you have any porn on this computer and
come with me
don't even need to shut it down normally
just flap do that alright one more
got upgrade okay alright wink okay boink
again what am i doing I don't have oh
God
there it is okay by the current through
the current same-day delivery plan ahead
get that right put it in the commuter
doodly-doo this why have horror music
playing over this okay let's take this
over here remove that scoodle you do a
Scootaloo do that sound there okie dokie
what if I just harvest all their [ __ ]
and just sell all their [ __ ] for scrap
what are they gonna do I'm sorry your
computer was lost to the wind like what
would happen if I actually did that oh
okay I'll put you right there all right
did I do it
oh [ __ ] that's not right that's not what
you call correct okay let's uh let's
take off the other panel let's do that
now okay all right I'm ready right next
to the other one baby you got it put
that bad boy right there right there oh
yeah there we go easy peasy
man that cable management is nice all
right put that bad boy this is the front
one put that bad boy right there
get the other okay nevermind I go
screwing the bad boy before I can move
on to the other bad boy all right move
on to this bad boy put that bad boy in
there let's screw on that bad boy that's
a good bad boy
all right let's boot this bad boy all
right how many times can I say the words
bad boy before it starts to lose all
Manning let's put this bad boy right
oh come here bad boy let's turn on this
bad boy
Oh oh hell yeah
Oh got any porn on here there must be
like some horrible secret Easter egg
right there's got to be some horrible
horrible horrible secret Easter egg
right collect mum Barney I think I lost
money on that same day delivery boink
all right bro can grab his gun boink
give me some help
Mike got it account overdrawn hey
here at mega Corp we know that life
doesn't always run smoothly so we
provide a free overdraft to our
our customers that's not that's not
realistic at all that's not at all
realistic oh I can't I'm done I'm done
I can't plays game anymore I can't do it
I imagine that there's some people out
there that would love and adore this
game and play it for hours and hours and
hours I'm not one of those people I have
to leave I have to go now okay I've got
one more simulator game for you here and
it is called Beast battle simulator now
there's another game that came out a
while ago and if you know all about
ultimate epic battle simulator totally
accurate battle simulator it's kind of
like all those but um I've never played
it before so I'm gonna do the ice lake
yeah let's go that one I don't know I
don't know I don't know how this game
goes I I saw pictures of it and it
seemed absolutely ridiculous from what I
was saying but then I get a lot of these
things seem ridiculous and turn out to
be well completely but oh my god ah go
on how how how how what the [ __ ] oh my
god oh my god oh my god okay alright
well I didn't expect that
alright you're gonna get it with loose
Eagles holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh
my god oh my god this is way cooler than
I ever thought it'd be oh wait no no no
no I already bought waves to put up any
sort of a fighting
[Laughter]
so cool I'm sorry this is super cool all
right wait okay hang on wait I got it
okay so Dino right
it's t-rex right okay so we got Oh
where's Jeff Goldblum oh come on there's
got to be Jeff Goldblum oh [ __ ]
alright let's do this let's do this
uh-huh I ain't so sure about this one
huh it's Don Zimmer yeah I want to start
out small before I go into anything like
crazy and huge okay wait okay you got a
Jeep
let's put one human in there a space
mage I can't put him in there oh come on
swordsman ah come on
all right well that's Jeff Goldblum this
is how did I not play this game sooner
this is amazing I love it all right now
we're gonna go into the ridiculous
crossbar bed oh [ __ ] in the form of a
penis all right and then farm age in the
form of yeah okay all right sure go go
oh boy well that lag oh okay who'd have
thought this game isn't very optimized
it seems to mmm seems to be a lot of
problems lag and whatnot okay well that
is that is an issue i I think we have
the matchup we've all been wondering
about ostriches vs. Megalodon Oh close
it wasn't even close you're gonna get
Maggie you're gonna get Megalodon oh oh
you go get it oh you think oh oh oh oh
oh you think you think you could okay
they just seem
okay they're just jumping into your
mouth at this point there oh oh [ __ ] oh
yeah a hand let me get a different map
let me let me get exit level this is
awesome all right challenges take down
the penguin squad oh okay shark
go no [ __ ] one shark all I need slide in
our mouth [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh I
think they won compy ah many compy go
can't be gonna get you hey oh wait oh
these penguins are powerful this bank
words are too good well nevermind this
coffee is on a rampage holy [ __ ] alright
yeah I got to take you over
Rahr Rahr you can't beat my spins of
death all right you know what
[ __ ] that [ __ ] these dumb sharks think
sand is water okay let me try - oh boy
okay you give me $10,000 well that's
your problem because I have big squawker
all right big squawkers whoa oh oh oh
that's not right what's happening but
they're on fire these guys shouldn't
have messed with the fader oh my god oh
my god the phoenixes are amazing oh
they're dead nevermind what does this
mean a variety of animals are seeding
your Tower in the desert survive the
waves I don't know if I want to round
one donkey elephant and t-rex oh wait I
can weaponize it
but can i oh no can I attach those to
get an S wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I can weaponize my giraffe and a
dog oh wait wait wait wait
but that where are they spawns bond
that's not elbow oh it's oh no the
giraffe is too high up you can't hit him
Oh No okay oh no it's a tiny dog the
brave pooper the brave pup er okay well
we're all done here let's let's set
beasts on fire BAM blizzard Mears oh
[ __ ] well we're [ __ ] early oh boy this
is a laugh and a half that did nothing
oh that's that's a problem okay giraffe
feet t-rex it's like what I said in the
beginning of this yes yeah
giraffe beats t-rex [ __ ] oh Jesus laser
no know what that is but I'm just gonna
do all all dogs alright let's go let's
go let's go [ __ ] let's go let's go
get him get him get him get him get a
puppies come on please please oh boy oh
boy this is the best thing I've ever
seen
oh this is great great oh [ __ ] okay I'm
done okay I'm done alright get it out
alright that's all for Beast battle
simulator that's fun that's fun that
good girl
very quickly but that was pretty fun so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know you thought down the
comments below if you want to play any
of these simulation games I'll provide
links in the description below and let
me know if there's any other cool
simulator games that you want me to play
in the future thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]